we've mentioned earlier this week this
recent Fox News poll which has been an
absolute treasure trove of interesting
public opinion and one of the things
that it found is that 54% of the country
wants Donald Trump impeached 50% wants
Trump impeached and removed from office
on yesterday's show I had video from Fox
& Friends where Brian Kilmeade was
stunned his word not mine that their own
poll found that half the country wants
Donald Trump removed now another one of
the really interesting things in this
Fox News poll was the section with
policy questions where it asked for
example what do you think of Elizabeth
Warren's wealth tax what do you think
about Donald Trump's us-mexico border
wall what do you think about Medicare
for all and the Fox News poll found that
the wealth tax is way more popular with
Americans than Donald Trump's border
wall 68% of the country supports
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax only 44%
of Americans support Donald Trump's
border wall the wealth tax is roughly
50% more popular than the border wall 55
ish percent more popular if you give
people a choice between let's tax really
rich people or let's build a wall in the
us-mexico border
way more people one attacks rich people
than want to build this wall the the the
the sort of incongruence is that if you
look at media coverage especially on
right-wing media they treat the wealth
tax like this absurd supposedly
socialist pipe dream while the wall is
treated as it's correct it's obvious
it's pragmatic it's effective it's just
a matter of getting Democrats to allow
Donald Trump the money he needs to build
the wall so it's really important to
understand that media coverage of policy
proposals and ideas is not reflective
number one of public opinion about those
policies ideas of those policy ideas and
number two of the degree to which the
policies are feasible now it's important
to also notice I want to be totally
transparent here because I know people
will say David you've got to talk about
the results
the poll about medicare-for-all the same
poll shows medicare-for-all as described
in the poll is not that popular there's
a question in this Fox News poll about
replacing the private health insurance
system that we have with a
government-run program it has only 41
percent support now we know from
experience that the wording on that
question really influences what people
say so on the one hand you can almost
guarantee low support for Medicare for
all type system if you say something
like do you support a government
takeover of health care that wording
will get a low level of support on the
other hand you can get a very high level
of support for Medicare for all if you
phrase it as should the government
provide a basic level of care to
everyone regardless of ability to pay
even though that's not exactly what
Medicare for all is but the point is the
wording of these health care questions
really influenced the support now that
being said I want to tell everyone Fox
News polls are considered pretty solid
they are rated a by a number of
different organizations that rate
pollsters including 538 this says
nothing about Fox News TV channel it
says nothing about the content of Fox
News Radio their polling is considered
relatively good polling so I do think we
need to accept when they say 68% favor
of wealth tax it's probably close to
that when they say only 41% support
replacing private insurance with a
government-run plant run plan it's
probably close to that that doesn't mean
that the question is asked in the way
that most clearly explains what it is
that's being proposed but that's part of
the problem part of the problem is the
messaging and that people don't
understand what it is that's being
proposed it also by the way doesn't mean
that a government-run program is bad all
the poll tells us is that there's a long
way to go in garnering more public
support and much of that lack of support
certainly comes from a lack of
understanding of what the proposals are
and because of successful smear
campaigns against these programs but my
message to you today is unless we
recognize that we have a lot of work to
do to make Medicare for all more popular
with the public we're going to have
trouble implementing it and by the way I
mean what you know the the Obama era and
the failure despite overwhelming public
support to pass universal background
checks for firearm purchases we know
that even with overwhelming public
support it can be very difficult to
actually make policy happen and make
things happen so it's an uphill battle
it's a worthwhile one but in the mean
time significantly more support for
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax than for
Donald Trump's wall based on Fox News
his own poll you won't hear much
discussion of that on Fox News's
airwaves but I encourage you to look at
the poll and look at these issue by
issue questions because the results are
very very interesting make sure you're
following the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show while
you're there follow me at David Pakman
let's take a quick break we have another
voter purge happening it's not just
Georgia this time we'll talk about that
after the break